how has the new godzilla movie helped
millie bobby brown dealing with the
pandemic
an epic film has hit the screen for only
the second time we'll get to see
godzilla and king kong battle
only this time the technology is way
better how much did cgi contribute to
creating the world of the film
why did alexander skarsgard learn sign
language what about the secret escapes
millie bobby brown and julian dennison
took while shooting on the gold coast
changing his direction no we're headed
straight for him
we're honestly so excited that millie
bobby brown is back to the big screen
and at only 17 the always busy actress
is no stranger to the monster content
world from her role on stranger things
and of course when she did the 2019
godzilla film
though this time she's really coming
into her own and we get to see her in a
more mature role
working on this film amid the pandemic
has actually been a really important
experience for the actress
through it she's been able to live in a
whole other world according to brown
the experience of working on this type
of film in particular is
really refreshing because she gets to be
immersed in a world of fantasy
and these otherworldly creations
shooting the film helped her to relieve
some of the stress that she'd been
feeling
and she was actually able to forget some
of the issues she was having in her own
life
while the film itself is of course very
dramatic our world is in such a chaotic
state right now that brown believes
people will enjoy watching it because it
can give us a break from our world and
allow us to totally invest in the
adventures of godzilla
and king kong for a couple of hours
this movie is of course centered on two
pretty impressive and monstrous
characters
so naturally the cast had to interact
with them but who were the actors
really acting opposite well it's not so
much who
but what most of the time when the
actors interacted with godzilla they
were communicating with the tennis ball
if the tennis ball was missing in action
sometimes it was actually just the first
assistant director who was holding up a
ragdoll and making some hand gestures
while not having a scene partner to act
with may seem tricky
millie bobby brown says it's actually a
really cool mystical experience
and because she has to visualize so much
on her own there's a kind of surreal
feel to the whole process shooting is
one thing but seeing the final product
can come as quite a surprise for the
actors since the energy in the movie is
so completely different to the bare and
simple settings they often found
themselves performing such intense
scenes in
what we see in the final cut is
terrifying monsters wreaking havoc and
destroying cities
but for brown her co-star godzilla
doesn't feel so intimidating
she's been able to see the character in
a different light and described him as a
beautiful creature
she has even confirmed that she is
definitely team godzilla
team god's a little square and then i'm
gonna wink at camera
one of the most interesting aspects of
godzilla vs kong is the significant
inclusion of sign language
child actor kaylee hoddle is deaf in
real life and so is her character in the
movie
the role she plays is actually quite
special because she's the only human
who's able to communicate with kong
cottle communicated that she was really
proud to be doing the film because of
the importance of having the deaf
community represented on screens
alexander skarsgard interacts with her
throughout the film and in order to be
able to communicate and develop a
stronger bond with her
skarsgard learned sign language he was
super impressed watching huddle work as
her precision and facial expressions
communicated so much
since hoddle is part of the deaf
community in real life she was able to
bring a unique authenticity because she
understands not only the language but
the culture
the performance is so special there's
some speculation that it might actually
be the one that really steals the film
she's the only one he'll communicate
with when it came to the sets
well what the cast and crew saw was
pretty different from what we see on
screen
see how empty this studio looks there
are only a few practical bits around the
set that act as markers in specific
locations
most of the movie was actually filmed on
large practical sets that had
huge green screens behind them to allow
the cgi to take over and really create
the environments
and of course monster characters to fill
the picture
the city where the third act of the
movie takes place was actually
completely designed by computers to
match the real city as closely as
possible
with a few futuristic additions to
upgrade the look a bit
not only did they recreate cities they
also adjusted and manipulated sizes of
real locations throughout hong kong so
the scale looked more realistic for kong
to move throughout the large buildings
almost as if they were giant trees
we can't talk about this film without
acknowledging these super impressive
water sequence
this was definitely a major part of that
200 million dollar budget
check out these underwater cameras and
the major contraptions that were needed
to shoot these scenes
audiences have never really seen
godzilla or kong in the water much
before
so seeing the way they interact with and
function in water brings a whole new
layer to these well-known characters
how about these explosion scenes we do
see some practical props with these
rocks but
overall it's far more calm without the
added cgi
but we would be lying if we said we
weren't totally blown away and impressed
by these performers all on their own
even without the effects there is no
doubt this is an action-packed film with
very talented performers bringing the
world to life
out the stellar young cast is julian
dennison there is no
shortage of talent from any of the age
groups for sure
just men being men you know for dennison
the project was actually really special
because it was the first time that he
really got to work with another
teenage actor since he was often the
only young actor on set in most of the
other productions he did
he and millie bobby brown automatically
had a special bond because
they both experienced the realities of
being child actors
they definitely had their fair share of
fun on set yeah
they're definitely having a good time a
lot of this laughter came from the fact
that the two often got to improvise
together when shooting
this added the naturalism and authentic
relationship we see between their two
characters
it may have taken a few more takes there
are even rumors that with all the
outtakes there's close to enough footage
to make a whole other film of just a gag
reel
the fun wasn't only reserved for the set
though the duo took advantage of
shooting on the gold coast to hit up
roller coasters on their days off
they even have their own extensive
secret handshake
sunrise sunset swimming fish remember
how we mentioned the movie cost 200
million to make
well it was quite a major project for
director adam wingard who had never
directed a film that cost more than
40 million they did shoot in australia
hong kong and hawaii so the hefty price
tag
isn't too surprising lingard was totally
ready for the challenge though and he
didn't approach the task lightly
he actually watched pretty much every
single godzilla and king kong film that
existed in preparation of directing this
one
he's expressed how necessary it was to
invest in research this way when working
on such a major franchise
after watching all the films it was the
1995 godzilla vs destroyer that really
hit him and inspired the way he wanted
to approach this one
all this background work helped winger
do justice to the movies which can
sometimes
stray into kind of weird territory when
done the right way
the films can show the monsters aren't
just monsters but characters we can
empathize and connect with
wynyard connected with the kong
character so much he actually edited
some parts of the script that he thought
were too harsh for kong because he felt
too bad directing anything harmful
towards this so-called monster
nathan are you okay
come on well let's just say this film
looks
incredible especially considering how
the godzilla and king kong movies used
to look
it's neat to know that the cast and crew
really had a great time on set together
creating such an epic film
and shows just how good all their
imagination skills are
how do you think this film will affect
the monster verse
[Music]